heute ist ein großer tag leute heute
geht's los ein highlight dieser welt
geländer also heute sehr erster band und
was macht man am ersten advent habe ich
natürlich dass seine tage wohl mein gott
[Musik]
ich bin nackt und rede mit dass du
arbeitest
was haben sie denn da sich dabei an hh
man kennt das beste spiel mit können sie
manchmal zu ihrem hobby ich mal sagen ey
pixar ist dass der netze unsere
zuschauer die zum beispiel nicht kennen
wird heute spielewelt für dich
eigentlich nicht wirklich festspiele
unterschreiben sagen sie waren sie mal
beim friseur oder interview jetzt sieht
auch gerade echt jude verletzungsbild zu
sehen unterschiede die regel ja und was
das schöne spiel der wunderbaren tag
früher viel gespielt haben wo es jetzt
sagen wir es nicht gestand später immer
holen
kurze frage zu ihrer pflanzen da drüben
soll sie so aussehen wie ein kleiner
sonnenbrand bekommt sonnenbrand liegt
aber auch nicht daran dass sie kleid
einfach nicht ließen
das problem war ich war zwei wochen in
köln und meine freundin die eigentlichen
auftrag die pflanzen und die leute
wollen erfahren haben kauft das ist
übertrieben
dazu hatten sich nicht so der outdoor
fitness typ bin mir so handeln geholten
diesen zu verstellbar und du brauchst
nicht tausende handeln soll hast einfach
hier deine ganz einstellen von jetzt
neun kilo steht auf beiden seiten halb
neun ein
und danach kann ich dir nur die neuen
kilogramm aus
brust training machen aber auch ich
natürlich mehr gewicht klar gehe ich
auch die firma 20 noch so eine kleine
bank da drüben dann holte die russin
hatte ich kein schreiben war dafür vor
was tut da weh weil deine lippen
vielleicht ein bisschen weg passieren
ein körperliches wrack gestern hat mir
ein kater heute ist man der zweiten cd
privater wie kann man zum donnerstag
nummer sieben kartons dahinter und das
ist ein ganz starker zuwachs das ist der
lohn immer das ist auch im westen
drogenkonsum klar hinter tainment die
lehrerschaft dahinter auch bereit etwas
für ihr verkaufen kann man den rheinpark
und du bist doch normalerweise die alle
auch behält echt mega cool drauf hat
klingelt ein paket ich bin ich hab
nichts bestellt ich weiß also sein
könnte
aber ich nächste woche erst
a
ganz einfach weil ich zusammen gemacht
als sie und sehr gut mittragen da die
man bei amazon die box gefunden
links
das riecht so ich hasse was haben wir
damit gute wohnungen wieder mal aber all
gefüllt würde ich sagen hoffen so
komisch ich hasse wassermelonen künftig
endlich die wohnung dekorieren fange
glaube ich mit dem schlafzimmer an den
ich mit dem platz war ich fange mit dem
wurden vorwürfe müssen
darauf habe ich keinen
wohnzimmer küche also dieser es wohnen
schlafen die wohn essbereich dass unser
hauptraum hier
der wird heute dekoriert weil er es
einigermaßen aufgeräumt war doch der
schon aufgrund und man kann ihn
dekorieren morgen
wie sollen wir sonst den leuten sagen ja
hagen kommt was sagen wir dann überhaupt
ich weiß was morgen kommt der untertanen
darf
[Musik]
ich freue mich so unglaublich auf diesen
blöden tannenbaum es ist glaube ich
sogar ganz klar dass ich heute schon das
alles hier dekoriere weil dann kommt der
baum morgen in ein dekoriertes umfeld
man fühlte sich wohl das top training
video des jahres 2020 auf youtube ist
kommt von weshalb sind die kommentare
beim richtigen youtube plötzlich bist du
bist perfekt steht gerade bei top gun
die videos auf 2020 auf youtube kommt
von der chemikerin und
wissenschaftsjournalisten die grünen
kämen unterlagen und ihrem kanal meiler
koma gesetzt gerade erst richtig los war
das video echt klasse und das zweit
platz zwei war männerwelten von yukon
klasse 6 ist die penny markt oku von
dadurch erwarten sie denn die marke noch
nicht geschaut hat schaut euch die penny
markt etwas platz acht ist dass blätter
zehn minuten apple programm la pamela
rendi würde sie jetzt sich wieder über
den winkel aufregen indem ich filme mit
das muss ich ja auch mal laufen dass
youtube game deswegen muss ich für die
aussehen hey leute heute zeige ich euch
meine drei millionen euro will das erste
von vier auch schon die kuriere
dekorieren
ich glaube das ist also haben wir die
ganze weihnachtsdeko mitgenommen so ist
denn unser weihnachts deko kissen die
höhe
michaels das tannenbaum deko die
brauchen und ich glaube ich hier habe
ich stoff sachen rein gemacht alles so
textilien soll dann kümmern wir uns erst
mal um das sofa das ist das leichteste
hier sorry das ist dieses jahr nicht so
eine krasse aufräumaktion gibt aber es
ist einfach aufgeräumt hier das vieh zu
sommerlich aus das hier ist einfach
unangenehm
das ist allen die auch zu der frische
farbe und diese naomi kissen die ich von
der von dem event geburtstag
die müssen auch auf jeden fall weg aus
kloster und dran dieses kommt die ganz
komplizierte anleitung hinlegen ja ist
es der das schreibwaren 1 mag das wenn
das so schlecht es zu viele kissen
sollte man auf eine couch auch nicht
haben doch so zwei grüne zwei tage
irgendwie die komplexität zurück ja das
sieht nett aus
wir bleiben auch mal in dieser ecke
hallo leute was ist unser tisch will
eine tischdeko haben die ein bisschen
einfacher runterzunehmen ist die kerze
ist der hammer ich glaube sie waren dem
westring adventskalender letztes jahr
drin die brend richtig schön aber läuft
kein wachs runter ich find sie mega gut
falls ihr sie suchen wollte es ist also
da drauf stand church ende vielleicht
hat das damit zu tun mit dem wachstum
sowie herbstdeko david gehen und was ein
großes problem
es war einfach alles so loos auf diesen
teller und immer wenn der deckel
rausholen wollen dann war sie total
umständlich das rauszuholen deswegen
muss ich mir hierfür auf jeden fall was
neues ausdenken das kommt jetzt erst mal
weg ich weiß nicht was ich davon halten
soll
ehrlich gesagt finde ich die immer so
ein bisschen altbacken wie al mabhouh
war so 2009 feelings für mich okay ich
gar nicht erwischen
kommt da einfach so was drauf bleiben
wir bei dieser konstruktion es sind
eigentlich sehr feste raus ich meine
dieser teller auch ich glaube er war
auch immer zwingend ich hätte mir dieses
jahr diesen westring adventskalender
holen sein letztes jahr waren so schöne
deko sachen da drin
die werde ich dieses jahr auf jeden fall
mal anbrennen ist 1 kalender drauf und
hier und dort schöner hilft irgendwie
sowas so werde ich ganz minimalistisch
ich mit zu viel tamtam bin eine kerze
und dann kann man das auch ihr
unternehmen wenn man sich einen kisten
also wenn man es da irgendwie raus holen
möchte schön hast überhaupt nichts
zusammen
who cares drachen als versprüht schon
küssen sie weist aber da geht noch mehr
[Musik]
wie kann man da nicht machen
eigentlich liebt so eine scheiße da sind
wir ganz simpel sagt wir kommen noch die
zuckerstangen fertig sodass bin ich auch
immer sehr süß aber wir haben leider
keine treppen oder irgendwie gute plätze
wo man sowas aufhängen kann dem feld
dekorieren leicht könnt ihr uns mit wir
sagen es war für plätzchen die wir
dieses jahr auf jeden fall packen wenn
ich habe wir werden heute beim gipfel
machen ist aufgefallen dass ich das
wirklich fast in jedem video sagen und
das nie passiert auch letztes jahr
wir wollten letztes jahr hatten wir dann
sogar kekse platzieren sorry plätzchen
gebacken für uns heutiges thema das ich
von meiner ex schwiegermutter bekommen
sagt man so was wie ex schwiegermutter
ich habe noch einen lichter vorrangig
können sie denn eigentlich in mein
zimmer arbeitszimmer aufhängen und jetzt
zeige ich euch sehr minimalistische deko
ich bin schon ganz minimalistisch aber
so es ist jetzt sehr sehr herzlich
ulrich verkaufen leute wir brauchen
jedes jahr genau welche fans die sachen
nein mein gott wie möglich wäre das wenn
man das als kommune benutzt während der
weihnachtszeit liebe diese kerze oh mein
gott
die habe ich von meiner schwiegermutter
schwiegermutter und ich liebe diese
kerze wirklich über alles
sie riecht fantastisch sie sieht
wunderschön aus und sie wurde auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt gekauft also mehr
weihnachten geht nicht an änderungen
getauscht ist dann schön dass es jetzt
unsere kerzen station für ungeliebte
kerzen die noch keinen platz haben
ich finde mit denen das wäre nie zu viel
weil er so groß und schwer
da ich nur dass unser tisch braucht halt
einfach keine deckung mehr weil da ja
quasi schon die deko ist kann ich den
vielleicht noch irgendwo hier 17
und das hier zu gehen voll gehen
mein einziges problem ist wo packe ich
meine mal sachen hin weil ich benutzt
passt einfach hier nie benutzt sie immer
wieder und ich finde es einfach mühselig
sie immer wieder also jeden arm quasi
wieder hervorzuholen obwohl sie jeden
abend an der gleichen stelle benutzt
werden bei sorgen kleiner kampf den team
und ich entgegen dafür möchte immer das
sachen sofort an ihren platz und
weggeräumt werden und ich endlich was
soll i sagt probiert was ganz verrücktes
neues aus
[Musik]
ein paar tage muss noch ein bisschen
richten also kleinere scheiße aus oder
aber dass so ein bisschen noch anstellen
[Musik]
ein bisschen cranes noch hier und da
aber was mir auffällt werde ich in den
nächsten tagen den weg machen kann man
so reinkommt dass sie irgendwie sehr
festlich aus jetzt kann man endlich mal
und adventskalender
leider waren diese pflanze habe ich
erfolgreich zerstört einfach die tut mir
leid perfekt ja weil diese idee hatte
zum bed klasse
für diese würde diese demo dabei haben
zum glück hab ich ja noch clips da
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gerade weil darin starb hier
geil alben produzieren so zusammengefügt
sind die westerländer ich meine von der
größe her ist das jetzt teams und teils
meiner aber darum kommt ja nicht alles
ist jetzt aber wirklich cool aus und
fängt die doch total scheiße aus aber
ich finde eigentlich hier finden die
beiden beinen
das war mein bruder
das war unser herbst kranz für die tür
und dm habe ich selber gemacht mit naomi
und vincent das war total die süße
aktion da sind mir zu nah nun angegangen
und die ganze vier verschiedene dinge
geholt und dieser kann zwar auch
überspringen nicht mit was anderem er
dann haben wir die neu beklebt und das
fand ich extrem süß jetzt kommt aber
unser klassischer von wo ist er
ich weiß es nicht aber ganz klassisch
der türkranz und ich weiß nicht wie
letztes jahr eine fußmatte gesehen habe
ich muss euch meine fußmatte zeigen die
nicht nur im keller ich muss sie holen
aber diese fußmatte
wir wissen nicht wer diese zwei großen
kisten mit dem dings vor unsere
natürliche so von wegen nummer eins
musste
[Musik]
sollte das schlimmste ist dass die leute
denken es ist scheiße ich konnte wieder
in seinen keller antiken welt irgendwie
herr ein bisschen vorstellen
dann haben wir uns gern erzählt ja auch
einen neben unserer keller die ganze
zeit diese zeit eingeräumt teppich da
irgendwie an der wand die leute tun
ihren top wert zwischen sind dies laut
doch die wissen wahrscheinlich leben
nummer 1 für fall gehört habe und dann
wissen wie das besondere und insgesamt
passen die uns alle hier im haus wo wir
machen gar nichts wissen ich letztes
jahr wie nikolaus gespielt ist macht es
auch wie der nachbar aus denkst dieses
jahr klebe ich auf jeden nikolaus
vanessa aus dem fünften also ich war auf
jeden fall im keller um diesen dicken
decken sagte ich hoffe diese keine
spinnen in diesem dicken sagt fragst du
dich lernst du deinen dicken sack gute
frage timo in meinem leben war ja stimmt
unser weihnachts fußmatte kenne schreibt
kann die wird jetzt von sich aus so
gepasst oh mein gott
remember alter damit das mal ich heute
auf jeden fall so bock drauf weil es
relativ spät schon also das war nicht so
viel wissen style noch
und bettina die leben von ikea china
klar titel schon uns aufbauen
das ist richtig mit steckdose und und
fifa boss
und hier ist sie die ich das ganze jahr
über gesucht habt die wahl welche
tischdecke ist eine sondersituation
gerade eine andere weihnachtliche
tischdecke gekauft habe aber die
weihnachtsbäckerei zuständig bei der
parade ab die schreib weihnachten das
ist die letzte aus dem weihnachtstag
es kommt wieder ins schlafzimmer
[Musik]
christmas time gebaut deinem arm ist
king was deko angeht andrea deinem deine
dekos aber das war ja auch jahrelange
erfahrungen der tu berlin schleimer
andrea sack gerade schneidet sie sich
ein
andrea ich bin auch du bist die schönste
die ich hier gesehen
die schönste mama die ski und ich habe
schon mal heute über schwiegermutter
geredet also die folge steht im zeichen
von meiner schwiegermutter also ich will
jetzt einmal dass die kamera chef timo
ihres freitagabend machen wir das nicht
wann fahren wir zum baumarkt um bei
kunden zu holen wollen dieses jahr den
bei kunden so krank wie möglich
dekorieren wie do it on monday
weihnachtszeit aber wirklich neunziger
oder auch wenn ich das so sehe das führt
sie sehr mag nach noch wichtiger an was
ihr wollt
betrüger
dessen echt viele farben hier habe ich
schon mal den pinsel und die zahlen zum
aufkleben für die töpfchen wie ich
vermute weiße weihnacht heißt dass
motiven ist wirklich sehr schön
es gibt also für die leute die schon mal
nachts noch nie vorher gemacht ich kenne
meine zahlen nur vom hörensagen
ich bin ja ein freund von ausmalen
geworden so einfach wie es mir jetzt
vorstellen wir müssen jetzt einfach bei
anfangen und uns durch kleben und
[Musik]
das sieht jetzt gut aus jetzt jetzt
jetzt sehe ich mich darin ein super
qualitativ hochwertiger pinsel macht man
testweise zumal ich fange an zu malen so
will man wissen wie das so ist weiß
sieht die farbe von innen aus diesen tui
eingesetzt weiß also man nicht weiter
interessant weil es mal jemand was
andere farbe tragen die leute die sich
nicht kennen werden denken dass es für
die kamera so machst wird beim lesen
außer dich natürlich bei diesem wirklich
so ist ich will die nummer zehn mal
[Musik]
21 minuten habe ich für displays hier
gebraucht ich habe 21
dafür 21 minuten ob ich dafür gebraucht
da finde ich hier so wie du glaubst wie
es wird wie es aussieht so bevor ich
mein leben weiterleben kann muss ich
mich in meine haare situation kümmern
das problem ist immer ich schminke mich
meistens sehr gut sehr ordentlich
meistens gibt mir sehr viel mühe beim
schminken und dann natürlich aber die
haare so das ist ja das ist keine frisur
hat ist dass das ist sowieso reden das
ist eine farbkorrektur sie sehen meine
haare viel heftiger aus als sie in echt
sind also die haben in der kamera so ein
baby ein schimmer was sie im normalen
nicht haben sind die achtziger nicht ich
will was neues ausprobieren das ganz
verrückt ist
wer von euch hat auch 300 haargummis und
weiß nie wo einst ist das klingt aber
nicht gut jetzt kann man sieht voll wo
noch viele haarfarbe war und wo nicht
einfach zumachen sollen sowie es wie
gesagt hat ich will die blonde machen
und die braunen lockig ich glaube nicht
dass das find out und wiesen die
vorstelle aber probieren geht über
studieren ich möchte zwei verschiedene
haarfarben warum kann ich nur zwei
verschiedenen strukturen machen können
kommen vielleicht finde ich gerade den
trend 1021 machen sich alle tickets zu
die haare weil sie es bei mir gesehen
haben wisst ihr was ich gerne hätte
diesen geist den andere blogger haben
weil dessen weißem hut ausgewählten
leuten diesen er erfolg zugeschickt ich
gehörte nicht dazu
ich hätte gern also da ist einfallslos
wie school mit seiner frechen platten
stehen dazwischen
doch dieser seite
[Musik]
oh mein gott es ist ein lob leute das
bisschen look
[Musik]
zumal man sich hinten die haare macht
dann sieht man ja schlecht ich lasse
deshalb also lasst euch nicht bei
während von den zwischenstand
ich glaube es wird fantastisch aussehen
[Musik]
verrückte auf meine echten haaren darauf
dass ich meine ich hab mir so eine
flockige braunhaarige perücke geholt vom
und das ist der fertige look ich hoffe
euch hat
[Musik]
ok es sieht so aus als ob ich eine
perücke drauf gesetzt hätte und
vergessenheit dem einen echten haare weg
zu packen ist dass ich meine so also
sieht eigentlich aus aber irgendwie ist
das gerade total leute ich sage euch
jetzt sieht das komisch aus aber 2021
gesagt sich alle laufen die was sagst du
zu meinen haaren und glatt sieht es
nicht aus als ob ich eine schlechte
perücke darauf hätte also oder ob ich
meine haare nicht weggemacht auf die
person die es sonst nicht aufgefallen
das ist der tasse lockige haare das
finde ich gut so kann ich mein mal nach
zahlen aus
ich brauche mal den richtigen look
keinen bock auf kekse backen werde ich
weiter malen kriegs oder wie gesagt ich
mache jetzt einfach überwältigend viele
aus
es ist auch gar nicht ehrlicher sieht
nicht nur so aus das ist überwältigend
viel
[Musik]
wünsche daraus mal hier guck mal hier
ist die 33 alter war das eigentlich
genug dran das ist jetzt spannend ja wie
fühlt sich an als wäre ich ein alter
bild restaurateure ganz vorsichtig
versucht das alte gemälde nicht zu
zerstören rentner der versucht den job
durch andere neue hobbys zu ersetzen ist
etwa ein wandkalender drin
ich glaube du hast box aufzumachen oder
oh ja das habe ich sogar geschenkt sie
wahrscheinlich selber haben wollte es
ist etwas weihnachtliches also wird
haben wir hier sieben grad aus kopf dran
machen und bild zusammenfügen mit ahnung
was sie sein soll nicht das gesicht das
hier ja ja sag jetzt ein sticker
sammelstelle hält gegen die kinder
schokolade 100
also das war ich auf jeden fall auf ich
habe mich an wenn die kamera schauen
könnt direkt in den kopf wie ich will
das machen
50 prozent der youtuber das so
provozieren wenn sie mit ihren
zuschauern reden und gern reinreden ja
und ungewohnt wenn man wie ich habe ja
ganz doll lieb haben wir jetzt diesen
job hier beenden tragen ist der schönste
tag im jahr
morgen kommt unser weihnachtsbaum das
gesamte revier unseres wohnzimmers und
so gibt es dann morgen weil mit dem
tannenbaum so sieht natürlich immer
alles viel weihnachtlicher aus ok dann
hoffe ich es hat euch heute gefallen und
wir sehen uns abschalten
tschüss